Joan Goldwasser a senior reporter with
Kiplinger's Personal Finance magazine
thanks for being here this morning I'm
happy to be here talking about credit
cards and the debt people faced with
credit cards that their ability to use
them how they can get caught in traps
talk to us about how things change over
the last couple of years with the
dodd-frank law and then other
legislation in Congress how have they
impacted things okay well starting in in
2010 that the card act was passed and
that instituted a number of reforms that
were helpful to consumers that said that
you had to get 45 days notice if your
rate was going to be raised for instance
and that you would have the opportunity
to pay off the balance at the old raid
it said that unique we're going to get
your bill 21 days in advance and it did
a number of things like that and so
those have been in effect basically for
almost two years and then a year later
dodd-frank was passed which was you know
an enormous piece of legislation and one
of the things that it did was create the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
which was the first you know institution
that was solely designed to protect sort
of every facet of consumers financial
life including you know their credit
cards and so it has been working you
know very assiduously for the last year
it's what did the Durbin amendment do
within the dodd-frank bill ok so the
Durbin amendment related to interchange
fees interchange fees are the fees that
a merchant pays every time you use that
piece of plastic and it basically cut
those fees in half and the idea was that
then concer prices would be lowered now
I'm not sure that people are actually
paying less for an item but in fact the
retailer's have benefited and well the
gas stations for instance of many gas
stations have always given you a
discount for cash and it is possible
that that might become a little more
common but it hasn't yet some other
things that were in the dodd-frank
legislation a debit card swipe fees
which we can talk about and then a
prohibition on network exclusivity what
is network exclusivity oh that means
that you can't
that you know we will only accept that a
retailer will only accept a certain
network with its for it when you use
your card they have to have at least two
so and the idea being that there's more
competition and therefore fees should be
lower but these are a little esoteric
really individual swipe fees though
something that everyone deals with right
when you use your debit card there
sometimes there's a fee so the idea is
the banks prefer that you actually sign
for your card because it's more
profitable for them the merchants prefer
that you use a pin number and so there
have been instances where you had to pay
you know if you did one or the other
depending on who was you know they going
to benefit and these fees a pretty much
your to have disappeared if you'd like
to talk about federal legislation how it
impacts your credit cards here are the
numbers to call Democrats 202 737 triple
zero one Republicans 202 737 triple zero
to and independent callers 20 to 60 to
80 205 Chung Joan Goldwasser what is the
least known thing about how federal
legislation has impacted people's
personal credit cards well it's hard to
know what's the least known what do you
mind if I were like I didn't realize the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau has
a method whereby if you are unhappy with
your bank your credit card issuer you
now have a toll-free number and a
website that you can go to and you know
you have maybe already complained to
them and said whatever it was that
happened was not right you overcharged
me whatever and now you can go to the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
commun Oh state your complaint in
writing they will then forward it to the
appropriate agency and they have a whole
mechanism whereby you know these
complaints are getting resolved in a
more systematic manner also they have
just it opened up a database so you can
look before you get a credit card and
see what issuer might have received more
complaints decide that perhaps you don't
want to get a credit card from that
company
and how much ownership or understanding
do you feel that Americans generally
have over their credit cards and their
credit card debt how in touch with it
are we I think people are more in touch
than they used to be however you know
during the recession's people often use
credit cards as sort of a lifeline this
is the way that they can pay some
necessary bills perhaps go to the
grocery store when you know they don't
have cash coming in it at the rate that
they used to so I think there are aware
of their dad it's just that you know and
during bad times it's a little harder to
pay it off one of the provisions from
the card act so says that your monthly
statement has to show how much you will
be paying if you pay only the minimum
amount on that credit card balance and
how much you will pay if you pay it off
within three years so your statement
every month gives you a better
indication of where you are and if
you're only able to pay the monthly
minimum amount you at least know how
much it's costing you which you might
not have realized before Ron joins us by
phone right now Democrats line in
Chesterfield New Hampshire good morning
good morning hey thank you for the for
the time this morning my question is a
little more broad is not real in-depth
into the credit card thing and
everything I'm quite thankful actually
for dodd-frank and the additional
regulations i think this far overdue my
question is since the banks were deemed
to be at least partially responsible for
a trillion of personal wealth recently
being destroyed from their loan shark
type of activities i was just wondering
why and no one's being prosecuted why
are they not financially responsible for
paying that back excuse me i guess the
question is how would you determine what
money is owed people's mortgages
obviously are larger than they were
then people's houses are worth but I
don't know how you can on an individual
basis say there for this individual you
know homeowner should receive X amount
of money I think it's hard to sort of
figure out the the amounts of money that
would go to individuals on how that
would be done Phil Republican color
Milwaukee good morning oh yeah hi um you
know what I I'm yet we're having a lot
of conversations about you know what how
do you get your budgets and in line I
think Wisconsin has shown the nation the
way on how to really get control of its
budget now it was a hard fight because
it's a difficult thing to deal with but
that is that the largest portions of
state and local governments uh budgets
are tensions and health care costs both
of them are unsustainable and and and
frankly that the direct result of
collective bargaining for public
employees so glad you're talking with
jungle Buster about credit cards and
personal spending do you have any
comments or questions about that no my
counter was on the problem on the on the
state budget ok let's go on to Lauren
Democratic caller in Frederick Maryland
hi hi good morning I just want to get
some clarity regarding the fees for
charges or our old draft fees for
charges under like five dollars or ten
dollars where one time thing was
charging like thirty-five dollars for a
small fee and secondly my other question
is for the consumer the new federal
agency the Consumer Protection Board
does that does that committee oversee
collection agencies because that's also
a huge problem with concern with
typically is related to the credit card
industry okay as far as the overdraft
fees for small purchases it really
depends on what your bank's policy has
become and in many cases banks have said
that they will not charge a fee if the
purchase is less than five dollars or
sometimes it's less than ten dollars if
they do it the
fees at the very biggest banks are about
$35 and you could you know be charged
that if you have opted-in now you can't
do have the opportunity now to say no
you do not want overdraft protection for
your ATM fees and when you use the ATM
and when you use your debit card to make
purchases and in that case the purchase
may be declined however the new
overdraft protection law does not cover
checks or a recurring automatic payment
if you have your mortgage automatically
deducted from your bank account even if
you opt out of overdraft protection you
still could be charged a fee for that
and yes Tom the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau really covers almost
every agency it recover it covers
mortgages student lenders every kind of
financial firm it has authority over
them the dodd-frank act does it affect
consumers more does it affect banks more
or does it affect the the retailers who
are accepting transactions with credit
cards and then dealing with the credit
card companies on the back end well it
really affects we not it doesn't really
affect retailer Taylor's per se but it
certainly affects consumers in the sense
that it is looking out for their
interests it is studying issues that are
of importance to consumers from you no
credit cards to mortgage lending to
collection agencies almost any facet of
the community that is involved with your
finances and it certainly affects the
banks obviously because they are being
regulated by them the the CP FB can
write regulations on its own rob is our
next caller Republican line in Rockport
New York hi hi it's Brockport would it
be okay well welcome Rob earlier oh
thank you very much the dodd-frank
Amendment hasn't done anything to
protect consumers I mean that the young
lady next to you who's talking about
people paying for their food
with credit cards I mean if your if the
economy is in such turmoil that you have
to use a credit card favorite food
that's not a good a good economy and as
a real estate broken for 20 years I know
that in western New York our economies
in the tank and the dodd-frank Amendment
does not help us at all and by the way
you were looking very hot today well
that is true I mean unfortunately
legislation per se cannot change the
economy I mean it can help us in terms
of the way our lives are impacted by you
know taking care of excesses regulating
the institutions that oversee that and
we're involved with on a daily basis but
a piece of legislation is not going to
change the economy per se oversight of
GOP tweets in and asks if you can
explain the role of the consumer
financial protection bureau in simple
terms ok basically it's your advocate
it's an ombudsman for you so it goes out
and takes an issue right now it's going
to be studying mortgage lending it's
going to look at the way when you buy a
house you know what kinds of documents
do you get it's going to simplify the
piece of paper that you get when you
were settling on your house so you can
understand the fees that you were being
charged and say i don't want to pay this
or why is this fee so high so it does
things like that i mean basically it you
know it's created this forum for people
to complain about their bank you know
and if it's charging you know has given
you a charge that you think is too high
it's really acting in your interest and
it's in every sense of you know your
financial life every aspect of it let's
hear from our next caller abu bakar
joins us from an asus virginia on our
independence line good morning good
morning and thank you for taking my call
yeah I just don't know a scam is good
wash &
when do credit card companies supposed
to charge a late payment fees when
somebody said payment has not omit BTC
within the three days of the build view
sorry what I did we sleep what kinds of
late babies oh please be yeah my wife my
wife sent been three days late and then
when they woulda beat him up as she was
charged $35 right okay mmhmm yeah i mean
the if you are late the credit card and
it can be you know one day light you
could be charged a late fee if you're a
very good consumer you can call them up
and in many cases the credit card
company if you have a good record will
waive the fee the first time but if they
don't then you are going to be stuck
paying you know this fee how much
control do consumers have over making
some of those phone calls taking action
advocating on their behalf when they
find charges on their bill that even if
they're you know they got a charge
because they were late they might have
an opportunity to get it waived how much
control do we have well there's always
the consumer service number on the
credit card itself and you should call I
mean yeah okay I'm a really good
customer you know I used my credit card
I pay the bill every month faithfully I
was out of town so I didn't get my mail
on times you know will you please wave
this fee and oftentimes if you are a
good customer they will waive the fee
it's always worth asking Carol's our
next caller Republican in Richmond
Virginia hi Carol I think people should
also remember are the unintended
consequences of the registration of
course with all regulation there's
always these unintended consequences
that nobody really wants to talk about
pleasing others are Carol but were the
ones that I have experienced and that we
are anticipating or the the bank fees
the increases bank fees for for bounced
checks have gone up and there are even
talks about
and they are coming soon of credit card
fees I remember when my mother used to
actually have credit cards and some
store cards and they used to charge a
monthly fee maybe ten dollars a month
and that went away of course that's
coming back also if our checking account
they're going to start having these all
of these feeds the banks are going to
get their money and it's unfortunate
that and I hope that now with the
current economy that is that the current
election the way the voters are acting
that they have now learned that what
it's really the problem because the
problem of the whole economy collapsing
started NBC both governments and that it
continues to ruin the economy comes from
DC and there let's get a response from
John Goldwasser about some of those
unintended consequences you were talking
about it is true the banks have lost a
lot of revenue the overdraft protection
legislation really cut into their
revenue a lot and the interchange fee
issue as well and she's absolutely right
the banks are profit-making institutions
and they are looking for ways to
increase their bottom line and to make
things better for themselves so some
fees have increased it is a little bit
harder to find a free checking account
but there are a lot of free checking
accounts out there if you go to a
community bank credit union or if you
want to stay with a big bank if you have
several accounts so you have a larger
balance with the that institution you
can often get a free checking account
and where if you're willing to bank
online John Goldwasser is a senior
reporter at Kiplinger's Personal Finance
magazine she covers banking and credit
for the magazine and website and she's
worked there for over 20 years there's a
house hearing coming up called the
impact of dodd-frank on customers credit
and job creators it's on Tuesday July
tenth here's a story it says Republican
lawmakers
to make dodd-frank repeal push the house
financial services committee will hold
hearings on the dodd-frank act with the
goal of demonstrating its negative
impact on individuals and businesses how
much of an effort is being made on
Capitol Hill to roll back dodd-frank
well the Republicans have never liked it
I mean they you know that there was a
lot of controversy over this legislation
in the first place and so the
Republicans certainly would like to roll
it back and the Democrats will you know
fight that and in this divided Congress
I don't think it will happen but you
never can say anything for sure the
story I was reading from is from a CFTC
law the website the credit card
provisions in particular in dodd-frank
are those controversial on Capitol Hill
there really aren't that many credit
card provisions per se in dodd-frank the
card act provisions you know went into
effect a year before so you have the
overdraft protection as part of
dodd-frank and the interchange fees but
the interchange fees are very
controversial but you have the
retailer's working very very hard to
keep those retain those because that was
an enormous boon for them I mean and
they won so I'm not sure whether they
can keep them in or not but they will
certainly try as hard as they can to
retain that on Twitter jbc writes in and
says that credit card companies raise
their rates to the hilt before these
federal laws kicked in and the raids
stay there even on perfect payers John
Goldwasser did you see that trend of
credit cards boosting their rates
interest rates have certainly gone up
that is true however if he means by
perfect payers people who pay on time
it's part you know then well if you keep
a balance obviously then you are
affected by the interest rate if you
manage to pay off your balance each
month then you know these fees and high
interest rates don't affect you very
much and there certainly are a lot of 0%
balance transfer offers out there right
now so if you do have a balance and you
want to try to take advantage of one of
these it's a good time to do
because those offers last for 12 or 15
months and you can at least you know pay
down that balance substantially without
paying any interest if you take
advantage of one of them Adam
Bloomington Indiana on our independent
line good morning good morning I had a
comment and a quick question my comment
was on the gentleman from New York when
he spoke about people using credit cards
for food which i think is a necessity
particularly for the long-term health of
people but i think the gentleman may be
forgetting is 2000 about 2007 people are
using a holmes's credit cards but also
it's a thing so I mean it's just kind of
different saying my question was about
the Consumer Protection Board from what
I understand currently it's not getting
funded and I don't know if that's going
to go forward as well because as you're
stating just a few moments ago
Republicans are not wanting to
dodd-frank act excuse me and one of the
ways to do that is to not fund it yeah
I'm not sure about its actual funding I
mean it it's certainly in existence now
it has fully staffed and it is working
very very hard I don't know what their
funding is and obviously that will be
you know a source of contention because
it is not a popular institution among
the Republicans and they will you're
right that's one way of making it less
effective Vinny is in Elko Nevada
Democrats line hi there hi I'd like to
uh tell we were waiting for a mortgage
from back in two thousand six and it
just wouldn't come through and she said
any day any day and finally in 2009
after the consumer section agency had
been and put in although the leader was
not named installed we were kind of
forced into a mortgage and the way they
did it was by we used our rent or
mortgage our landlord as a reference and
the rest of the landlord got involved
and made it they were going to throw us
out of the apartment our credit was
great everything was great and the same
day that we were ready
uh to go to a closing the landlord
flipped out on us which made us sign the
papers even though we didn't want to
sign them because we saw a lot of
problems so I wanted to alert everybody
to be careful don't let your landlord if
you're renting know that you're about to
close because they use that and I
wondered if you ever heard anything like
that thank you I'll take my intro fly no
I'm afraid I don't know of any instance
like that but I don't follow housing
that much so I'm sure that there are
horror stories everywhere here's an
example of a piece that Joan Goldwasser
wrote for kiplinger last summer it's
seven little-known credit card perks
points and cash back or only a fraction
of things your credit card can do for
you John Goldwasser give us some tips
and hints about of things consumers just
don't know about taking advantage of
credit cards well many times your credit
card will double the warranty on
something that you have purchased if it
came with a one-year warranty it might
increase it to two years it also might
give you option of repair having
something repaired if it's brand new and
it breaks the credit card company will
have a service where it can be repaired
or replaced sometimes you can get travel
insurance through your credit card
company some of times there's even
concierge service so you can get tickets
to some sign of sold-out event early
they're things like well of course the
renting an automobile you can waive all
of those fees that they ask you to sign
for because your credit card may very
well cover them Mike Republican caller
Portsmouth Virginia good morning hey
good morning up until a make a statement
or how some consume found that forth on
Frank but I like to make a statement
about abuses that some consumers do i
was in mine one morning in a local store
very early in the morning people going
to work this my all of us in there going
to work a guy was standing in front of
us he was on his cell phone and he took
I don't know what was going on with it
the credit card machine but once it
corrected itself
whatever he was doing only thing he was
fine was to pack of cigarettes and a
cigar now at the end of the month does
he realized that he is going to pay
another charge for that two packs of
cigarettes and a cigar and yet we
complain about credit cards but we must
be responsible of what own the amount
that we buy me some are you like are you
saying that he will be paying interest
rates because he put it on his credit
card yeah I mean just what so let's get
some clarification from John Goldwasser
about when your charge fees for using
your credit card well he may well have
been using a debit card also and more
there are more people using debit cards
now than than credit cards actually and
people do go to Starbucks or McDonald's
or places like that and spend you know a
few dollars and use their debit cards
and in that case the money is coming
directly out of your checking account so
you aren't incurring fees and if you
haven't signed up for if you've opted
out of overdraft protection for some
reason your account is below you know
the amount you're spending it will be
declined you might be momentarily
embarrassed but you won't be charged
thirty-five dollars for that cup of
coffee and when you buy something with a
credit card even if it's a low amount of
money where are their fees are their
fees are we just talking about if you
don't pay off your whole balance no
we're only kind it's just the interest
if you don't pay off your balance there
isn't going to be a fee just because
you've used a credit card no let's go to
Portsmouth Arkansas koel independent
call or good morning so the names go
Joel excuse me go right ahead I was
calling burst law uh-uh 2 comments first
of all one is in regards to uh uh gear
out numbers system on the telephone
numbers need to leave up a little longer
i'm on the screen they're not there that
often and when they are they're not
they're very long very hard to catch
okay thanks for the feedback Joel what's
your comment or question for John
Goldwasser okay on the credit card you
know when you see you application for
credit cards he'll tell you while you're
a pre
proved for up to $1,500 say for example
on credit card and so you apply for the
credit card and then they come back and
say well we improved you for a thousand
dollars but then they only really give
you credit for 925 dollars and they
charge you a $75 fee for something you
haven't even used yet I don't understand
that and why should that be okay when
you get one of those pre-approval
letters if you read the fine print it
always says subject to your credit
history so you know you might be quote
pre-approved for a card with a large
credit limit and a low interest rate but
if when the you sign that form and fill
out the application and the credit card
company reviews it and looks at your
credit history and your credit score
they might determine that you're not
quite as credit worthy as you know you
would hope and so they will give you a
lower credit limit and they might charge
you a higher interest rate and you know
it should have you the fee for any
annual fee on a credit card will be
stated quite clearly I mean there's no
fee that is not going to be told to you
in advance they'll tell you either this
credit card has no annual fee or a $19
annual fee or you know a $75 annual fee
but that shouldn't be a surprise do you
have a sentence jungle wasser of how
many Americans pay off their credit card
bill in full every month versus
carryover a balance which then gets
charged interest it's about thirty
thirty-five percent that actually pay
off in their entire balance every month
and Sasha tweets in and points out that
the caller called earlier and talked
about sitting behind a gentleman who was
buying cigarettes with what he thought
was a credit card sasha says well if he
pays off the balance at the end of the
month he does not Oh additional fees he
doesn't have to pay interest rates our
next caller is neat Democrats line in
Gaithersburg Maryland good morning nee
are you with us I think we lost that
caller are you here yeah I'm here okay
go right ahead okay um thank you
the opportunity my name is me Bannerman
and I want to make two two quick
comments or one question and a comment
the first one is this why is it that
when we pay our mortgage the money goes
predominantly towards interest and and
not let's see 5050 towards principle I
think that would be the best economic
stimulus where we are able to pay our
loans i had a time cause it's not being
applied towards interest on the front
end but equally towards principal and
interest and secondly there's this
process where you can link your checking
accounts to your savings account right
so if you have money in your savings
account whenever you out spend your
checking account automatically take it
out of your savings account but then the
banks want to charge you for your own
money because you're the money in the
savings account is money that is yours
and if they have to leverage that money
then they try to bring in all kinds of
fees and what can we do or what kind of
movement can we start to stop these kind
of hidden charges or charges that to me
are to me is just pure greed well it is
absolutely true if you have a link to
count that is one way of avoiding
overdraft fees and you have your
checking account linked to a savings
account or a money market account and
you will pay a fee he's absolutely right
it's around ten to twelve dollars which
is less than a $35 over dressy I don't
know how you're going to get the banks
to stop doing that that they say it's
look you know the cost of doing business
and they are in the business to make
money you can try a consumer movement
like you know Occupy Wall Street and see
if it works how much control do
consumers have over their credit card
information we've been reading about
breaches and security hackers taking
credit card information and
then what do you do as a consumer how
much access do you have to who took your
number what happens to your data
unfortunately you don't have a whole lot
of control over that you will get a
statement from your credit card company
every month not every month sorry but at
least once a year saying you know this
is information that we share and this is
you know you can opt out of parts of it
but they are going to share it with
their partners there it is available to
the institution with which you do
business and it seems as if these
systems although they are supposed to be
foolproof and failsafe or ID theft and
hackers do fail sometimes Becky picks up
on something you said earlier and says
so much for the death of free checking
she heard you talk about free checking
accounts being something that people can
get are we seeing the shrinkage of the
free checking accounts that we thought
we might the banks had come out and said
well if you take away our ability to
charge fees in one place we'll have to
charge them someplace else the big banks
have made it a little tougher to get a
free checking account they've raised the
minimum balance they require but even
with the big banks if you you know
bundle all of your financial life at the
bank you can qualify for a free checking
account and the community banks really
offer free checking accounts in as large
a number as they ever did and so do the
credit union so if you just do a little
bit of research it's not that difficult
to find a free checking account bob is
our next caller republican from shelton
connecticut speaking with joan
Goldwasser go ahead Bob oh hi thanks for
taking me it seems to me the talk about
fees is minor compared to the very high
interest rates on unpaid balances like
in the 20 low twenty percent did
dodd-frank address that could that be
handled federally you had said I think
that legislation can't help the economy
but putting a cap on the interest rates
more like ten percent you know something
Rio's reasonable is much more important
than the fees that the banks are
charging general that's covered usually
state by state and there are
some states that have Ussery laws that
are where the rates are much lower than
other states but in general know that
rates can be pretty high and penalty
rates can certainly be in the in the
twenty percent range let's hear from
Arthur independent caller Edgewood New
Jersey good morning Arthur yes good
morning yeah I'm calling this is about
debit credit cards that banks give you
I'm wondering why these credit score
company if you're very responsible with
your money and you don't use a credit
card or have a credit card because of
the problems you could run into you know
accumulating debt if you use your debit
card and your credit card very
responsible because you don't want to
spend money you don't have when you go
for credit they tell you you know you
don't have bad credit but you don't have
a history of credit because they don't
evaluate debit cards as a credit type of
school did that happen to you Arthur oh
yeah it's all the time I mean for two
years I had a payment auto Lincoln that
I bought for my your business and I at
the time my credit wasn't that good but
I i was making payments nine hundred and
thirty four dollars a month for two
years i didn't miss one payment at all
and i was never late and then a couple
of years later I went to get credit you
know cuz i wanted to purchase another
vehicle and because i didn't do anything
within those those other couple of years
because i didn't use credit card at all
i just was using my debit card and
spending money that i had the bank and I
couldn't get credit because they said
you know I didn't have a credit history
and I don't understand that so Arthur
brings up the point of if you're a
responsible spender not getting credit
card spending within your means only
using a debit card to make transactions
you can be penalized because you don't
build a credit history
that's true it's a problem you have
what's called a thin file and debit
cards do not get reported to the credit
bureaus so if you only use your debit
card you sort almost don't exist unless
you have a mortgage or a student loan or
a car loan if you have some other kind
of debt that's getting reported you will
build up at your credit history that way
but if you don't you it's a problem it's
a problem also for people who rent
although the credit bureaus are trying
to figure out a way to include those
people if you pay your rent on time to
get landlords to report to the credit
bureaus so you do have a little bit more
of a credit history do you write about
recommendations and kiplinger's about
ways people can build credit if they are
denied a credit card because the company
says you just don't have enough credit
to earn one are there ways you can build
it up by taking out car loans and the
like right I mean obviously I don't
recommend that you take out a loan for
money unless you really need it but yeah
if you have a car loan and it car loans
are one of the things that it's much
easier to get right now for car
companies lending money and much more
generously than other you know kinds of
institutions but that will go on your
credit report and if you can't get a
credit card in any other way there are
secured credit cards and with a secured
card what you do is deposit a certain
amount of money with the bank and that
becomes your line of credit and you can
charge against that it will become your
credit limit and so if you use that
credit card responsibly paying it off
every month often at the end of a year
you will qualify for a regular credit
card from that particular Bank Tony
shares his opinion on Twitter and says
debit cards are one of the ways to
exploit careless consumers Tina is a
Republican caller in Alexandria Virginia
good morning good morning welcome to
Washington journal go ahead yes I come
in this is directly in regards to the
gentleman from Gaithersburg calling
about the bank charges I just want to
let him know that if he opens up an
account at a federal credit union you
probably will not have those charges
credit
yeah it's just more about them credit
unions are very consumer friendly and
right now almost anyone can find a
credit union that they can belong to if
there isn't one in your community which
there probably is there's some credit
unions that you can join the just by
joining an organization you might have
to pay anywhere from five to twenty
dollars but you will then qualify so
there there is a credit union in this
country that anyone because can become a
member of our caller a few moments ago
Arthur talked about the hard time he was
having getting a credit card but Dennis
tweets in and says I get at least one
credit card offer per day how can I stop
this extreme volume of offers we're
seeing the flip side right if you have
good credit you are somebody that the
banks would like to you know try to lure
away from you know another institution
and get you to become you know credit
card holder of theirs and so they are
sending out solicitations and feel you
know you can possibly get rid of it by
putting yourself on you know one of the
anti-spam list but if you already do
business with that institution you're
probably getting some mail Old Lyme
Connecticut Elizabeth Democrats lying
good morning good morning i am calling
and i am a first-time caller and I'm
nervous that's okay welcome okay thank
you I love c-span I'm calling because I
discovered a scam that I was involved in
without my knowledge and I would like to
just explain how I handled it and what I
learned from it the point was that i was
in a kind of busy period of my life and
could not and was not watching my credit
bill as closely as I could and when I
finally settle down and could do that I
realized that I was getting a charge
twice a month of twelve dollars each
from two different companies and it had
gone on for quite some time and I also
discovered there was a phone number
after this chart
and that if i called it you know i would
find out who it was but i first went on
the web and tried to find something
about this and someone on the web had
had a similar experience and this it was
a woman and she she said that if you
call them directly and challenge this
they will immediately remove the fee
return your money etc etc so i did this
i started that way and i got a an
immediate response the minute i said to
say oh no no no and what you're you know
name and address and whatever and they
they'll send you a kind of a form that
you had to sign and part of that was
that you would never kind of sue them
for what they did so I did that and I I
did get the money back but I decided to
pursue it further and research the
company that sent the forms and it
turned out it was one company in this
case it was located in Stamford
Connecticut it had about 35 different
names of companies like this that was on
my credit card I only had two of them
but that and I found further that this
is a firm that was dealing with banks
that was trying to help them to find
ways to increase their income and one of
the things that they did was they would
a certain firm I know the one that I got
caught in when you call them if it if it
said would you like a discount the next
time you buy from this product and you
said yes all of your your information
was passed on to that company Elizabeth
let me ask you what were they charging
you for what was the service they were
claiming oh they did the service was in
one case it was an identity protection
and in another case and cannot exactly
remember how they phrased it but they
said that I looked at up and you know
when you get when you get credit card
protection supposedly and they they
somebody get your card that they you
won't have to pay more than the first
fifty dollars something like this ok so
i guess it gets lost or stolen we're
just about out of time but thanks for
sharing your story and let's go to joan
Goldwasser and get her reflections on
this right you have to be very careful
often if you answer an ad for a free
credit score or a free credit report if
you don't go to annualcreditreport.com
where your credit report is always free
because it's sponsored by the Federal
Trade Commission but if you go to one of
the others that's it may be free credit
report.com you will get a free credit
report but you may have inadvertently
signed up for credit monitoring or ID
protection and then you will find that
you are suddenly being charged you know
ten dollars a month twelve dollars a
month something like that and you know
you so you should always be very careful
you know before you when you get
something that's free that it doesn't
have some strings attached and nobody
should ever have to if your credit card
is stolen or lost you are protected by
law only have to you only have to pay
for the first fifty dollars and in most
cases you won't have to pay that Visa
and MasterCard have rules saying that
there is you know complete liability and
you don't even have to pay that first
fifty dollar fee Joan Goldwasser senior
reporter at Kiplinger's Personal Finance
magazine she writes for both the
magazine and website covering banking
and credit issues thanks so much thank
you